thanks for joining us America we are
glad you're with us David is in San
Antonio hi David how are you doing good
appreciate you offering the white horse
certainly sir how can we help I've got
to start taking money out of the IRA and
I needed to find out was I've gotta take
a percentage up here are you 70 and a
half yeah I got old ha ha ha ha ha
better than the alternative okay and so
you have them you have the mandatory
distribution rules okay yes and the rest
of it what percentage should be bonds
what should be stocks and they have so
many funds that I just have to go by
what you know percent wise well I'm not
a fan of bonds in this especially in
this current environment because as
interest rates go up the value of bonds
go down and we are at unusually low
interest rates right and so as the
mortgage rates as you hear mortgage
rates go from 4 to 5 you're going to see
the value of your bond go down
dramatically and so I don't want you to
I don't put you into something that I
think is going to go down over the next
10 years I mean I don't think we're
going to be at 3 percent interest rates
or 4 percent interest rates for 10 years
I really don't I mean it's nice but I
don't think it's going to happen so I'm
not a fan of that and and I don't do
single stocks you probably know that
from listening to me so I'm going to be
is in mutual funds and I kind of think
that's what you're talking about our
mutual funds correct yeah actually it's
in a annuity it's in an annuity okay but
there are mutual funds within the
annuity that you can choose correct yeah
there's about a hundred of them yes yeah
okay so I'm going to be in probably four
types of mutual funds growth growth and
income international and I'm probably
going to put some in some balanced funds
although normally your balanced funds
are going to have some bonds in them a
lot of the balanced funds have moved
away from bonds right now but
they see the same thing I see that
prevailing interest rates are unusually
low so balanced is the calmest growth
and income as the next calmest growth is
the next comest and then international
obviously is stocks and companies that
are overseas if your spread across those
four that's an unusual portfolio
according to financial planning people
some of them but here's what I see
unless you're ill you probably are going
to live another 20 or 25 years the
average death age of a male is 76 a
female is 78 but that includes infant
mortality teenage death and so on when
you make it to 70 years old in pretty
decent condition it's not unusual at all
live into your 90s so you got 20 years
you got outpace inflation and if we
think about what gasoline or a loaf of
bread cost 20 years ago I want you to be
making some money during that 20 years
yeah and so that's how I would have that
at that annuity allocated if I were 70
years old and by the way I'm 53 and that
is how my retirement is allocated except
I don't have a balanced I have a more
aggressive I have the aggressive growth
stock mutual funds to the balanced fund
right okay I know what's up I'm still
working but that's uh I keep trying to
retire they won't let me what do you do
plumbing oh cool cool how much is in
your annuities in your 401ks in your
nest egg uh Wells Fargo says about 1.8
excellent and how long you been a
plumber uh since 1968 good for you good
for you let me ask you something just to
teach some of the people that are 28
that are listening to you and me talk
right now
what was your average income since 1968
do you think well it's 72 now okay and
it's that remote what's the most you
ever made um I did work overseas for a
couple of years that was I would did a
lot better yeah but other
that other than that when you were
stateside your normal income was in the
70s yes of course back I would have got
married in 65 of fact enough groceries
last for a month was $25 yeah exactly
exactly and so how did you come about
the 1.8 million have you saved every
month
your whole life uh well Earl Nightingale
in Napoleon Hill taught me well mm-hmm
yeah okay but I mean mathematically did
you invest every month I did most of the
time yes okay you know just a steady
supply of into that ventolin and so if
you were going to sit down and advise a
28 year old or a 26 year old that was
just getting married starting their
careers uro you're a walking example of
as a plumber making 70 80 thousand
dollars a year a couple times you made
more than that working overseas you were
able to amass 1.8 million dollars in
mutual funds right yeah okay so when
everybody says that oh you can't make
money and you know you don't need to be
investing in the market's crazy and all
that you just kept going the whole time
guys correct yeah yeah and here you sit
worth two million dollars you got
grandkids three yeah you're teaching
them how to do what you did I'm trying
okay good you're good man absolutely
amazing thank you for letting me
interview you for a second because
you're what's known as The Millionaire
Next Door in that wonderful America
that's the land you live in and when you
sit around and tell me that the economy
is structurally flawed I will point to
you and say there's a plumber named
David in San Antonio that's worth almost
two million he's worth over two million
dollars we didn't ask about his house
that was just his mutual funds and when
you tell me that you shouldn't invest
the way Dave Ramsey teaches because Dave
Ramsey doesn't know what he's talking
about Dave Ramsey's an idiot investing
in good mutual funds and projecting that
the market is going to cause you to win
oh but what about the Lost Decade what
about the downturns and what about this
and what about that and let's just wring
our hands and do nothing and hope that
Barack Obama will save us
it's not gonna work for you I don't work
for you you see David you know the
working man can't get ahead I think
David to tell you he's a working man I'm
a working man too by the way I don't
turn a wrench but I work my butt off so
I think David is a working man they got
a head you know who are all Nightingale
in it by the way is he's the guy who did
the strangest secret that we talked
about one day not long ago here on the
air strangest secret is you become what
you think about and if you don't set
goals you will always lose so men like
David very quietly become worth two
million dollars while living in the
house next door to somebody who spends
everything they make
like they're in the government or
something that guy right there is a
living breathing example of who you need
to think about being he gets up and goes
to work he he goes to work really when
he doesn't feel like going to work some
days you can count on David I don't know
David I never met him and I'll just tell
you that's a guy you can count on he
wouldn't be where he is if he if he if
you couldn't he's worthy of trust
trustworthy faithful and these the end
and yet you have some punks camping out
on Wall Street and your Punk's saying
that the David is evil because he's
built wealth and did you know wealth is
not distributed equally did you know
that there's a wealth distribution
that's not fair it's so bad these poor
little people don't have any money
because they haven't worked and saved
like David did and you have no right to
take his money that's his money and
anyone who tries to take his money in
the name of a government should be fired
from their job you should keep your
hands off of David's money
it's his you have no right to it your
whining sniveling little whistle Fayyad
self has no right to that that is his
grandchildren's money and your estate
tax
should not touch it it doesn't currently
but it has in the past and there's all
these people out there running around
talking about the the wealth needs to be
redistributed no it doesn't because some
of you didn't work as hard as David has
worked and you weren't as diligent in
saving as David and so you have no right
to his money so for you to redistribute
his wealth is called theft you freak
just don't get me started can you tell I
love guys like that he's my hero that's
what makes this country great we need
more David's unless if you listens this
is the Dave Ramsey show